[Music]  have your kids been bad this year  Wow teach him a lesson I pull on us the  world's greatest not a toy store  it's a coal abrasion we've ruined  Christmases one pool at a time my son's  been a real [ __ ] come forward yeah  so here's how it works just bring in  something your kid once like an Xbox and  then I'll replace it with the lump of  coal then I take the presents and burn  them off and in less than a hundred  years we'll have more coal laughs is  like a box of calls I'm Forrest love I  need to punish my son here's some coal  thing is he wants to be a coal miner  he loves coal here's an iPad he'll hate  this Thanks  [Music]  because  this lady I knocked up once you get  married you got coal in a ring box  I do but enough talk watch these real  life results you're right I have been  bad this year  ha ha ha I love you now nice with the  Christmas miracle my parents did it for  me and look how I turned out in one  [Laughter]  [Applause]  [Music]  this guy's terrible